[Music]
I'll welcome good afternoon everybody I
meet I'm the technical lead for
architecture components and I'm here
joining with Kel it's also part of the
team so today we are going to talk about
persistence now if this is a loading
screen this is all my favorite screen
said no one no one ever said I like the
way especially if there's some content
did they have already seen and if you
are making the user wait to see the same
content
it's horrible like you're a bad person
and everything so now how to fix this we
purchase the data this is what we
recommend developers whatever
information you fetch from your network
different data sources save it to this
so that if your application is restarted
when there is no network conditions you
can show something to the user you can
make that experience seamless let me say
purchase on Android we know this is a
very crowded sphere there is out of
different options different companies
and most of these solutions are really
really good solutions but if you come to
Andrew it and like if you're new to the
platform what you would do you will
check what is inside the framework
already so there's these three things
that come with the standard library and
if you read about them you realize that
if you want to put structured data then
you want to go with SQLite SQLite is
something we have been shipping since
Android 1 it's a proven technology works
very well so you go ahead and say ok I
know a scale I want to use SQLite you go
to this page this is the very first page
you see this is horrible this is like
it's kind of trying to say you know what
you don't want the person it's not what
we meant but this is what we have so you
say you know what let's let's look at
this page like we want to make this
better right let's get this page it's
trying to say I want to select these
columns with this constraint
with this order so if you look at this
this is a very very simple SQL query but
it takes a lot of stuff to write it you
need to define all these concepts which
are not even visible on this page so I
want to say okay
there should be some room for
improvement and came up with room which
is an object mapping library for SQLite
now okay we said okay let's let's step
back we said writing the same thing with
SQL is a lot shorter a lot nicer so
let's go back to our roots which now
there's a nice karakuri that we assign
it a string it is standard SQLite now of
course if it is like this the we cannot
understand it we low annotation so we
put it inside an annotation and it is
inside annotation now you want to get
the response from the query want to say
well put it into a method so we can
understand what the query wants to
return now we know that this is a query
it wants to fish these columns from this
table and with this constraint but if
you look at the constraint there is
actually a bind parameter this is a
SQLite standard byte parameter syntax we
didn't came up with this so where do we
get this bind parameters how do you get
parameters to your functions from the
function arguments so we put a test the
most obvious place to get this argument
from and none last but not least we want
to know what it wants to return okay so
it's returning list of weeds now of
course there's a feed class so it needs
to be somewhere we have that class and I
want to put this query inside that data
access object that's what does stands
for because you don't want to have your
application making database queries
along the code base you want to put
these into certain causes which we call
data access objects so said all we need
to tell the room that this is a doll and
I mean it's a child room that feed is
some class that it would like the purses
into a database last but not least we
need the database to put these two
things together that needs to expand the
room database cost and so the feed dog
we defined us we just say this database
has this tall
and the feed entity we define that we
put inside data so you can have multiple
entities multiple dolls you can actually
have multiple database definitions that
access the same dolls as long as
whatever schema you define in that
database works with the dolls and
entities wrong with results once you
have all that description you can get
the implementation of the database
through this builder it's very similar
to how you use retrofit dagger you
provide the you define the interfaces we
provide the implementation now of course
because we are doing the implementation
select queries are very specific we
really don't know how you will select
but there are other queries that you
would like to use or something into
database so we said okay we can just
define other annotations to make it
easier for you inside these annotations
these are actually very very flexible
you can say we could pass multiple
arguments like if you read this method
it says inside both you really want to
enjoy both of them to database and the
room understand this you can send a list
of items you can send variable arguments
multiple parameters like if it is
readable room we'll make it work you can
even say like if your Titans are this
thing if there's a unique key conflict
in the database do this so you can also
specify these constraints so since we
have the insert annotation we have
similarly delete or update annotations
just for the very common tasks now this
so we said we just starts up on that
SQLite but there are some cases where
writing SQLite is harder for example I
have this query where I want to query
these feeds but I'm trying to return a
list of feed which means like I want to
get multiple feed items right so that
means I want to get them by ID so I
probably want to pass multiple IDs now
in SQL you will do this in these IDs but
you need to know how many IDs you have
so you can put that number of bind
parameters but this is some information
we don't know while writing this query
right well that's okay room can
understand it if whatever the
mitr you are passing to a function is a
collection rule knows that okay
this they want to have multiple bind
parameters at runtime we will generate
the right query for you and we will do
that san dimas' NL a fundamentalist
doesn't really matter if it is if room
can understand it will do it for you now
the most important part about room is
that once we let you define all these
things let your room understand these
queries not just say like you know take
this SQL and then like compile time
generate the code room understands it
knows what you are trying to do and this
gives us a lot of power for example if
the room looks at the screen it says
okay this is a select query with this
bind parameter which is passing as a
string
I knows it is from the feed table and it
wants to return items this feeds the
room goes and says ok can I relate this
yes the tail the table has these three
columns the feed item has these three
columns these match verify you could
have another card instead of that feed
that has these three fields rumors to
work now after this verification let's
say you made a typo right like the
reason why we define all those constants
or use Java builders is also avoid these
piping like mistyping queries room can
do this relation for you similarly Java
code right you don't use builders to
write java code you write your Java code
compiles tells you if it is wrong and
the ID helps you with this so the reason
why we don't have builders is that we
think helping you write SQL query is the
job of Android studio which they are
working on it but once you write the
query room verifies that it is correct
so if you do this mistake room will not
let you compile the application
similarly if you access some columns
that doesn't exist in the database again
it will be a compile time error by the
way it can be any query you might be
joining five tables room will still
understand you might have grouping like
almost anything in SQL let's say we made
it mistake like that where we only fetch
the subtype
: but we want to return this as they fit
now in this case the feed object also
has a subtitle : so this might be
intentional maybe you are going to fill
in those fields later on or you made a
mistake we don't know in this case room
just generates the warning it says hey
feed classes to other fields that you
are not returning from the query it will
just give you all the details well what
the query returns maybe you made a typo
and what are the fields in the comb in
the entity now there are two ways you
can get rid of this morning the first
thing you can do maybe you really want
to return them as feed instances and I
can tell the room to ignore it now I
know what I'm doing
suppress this morning alternatively you
can just create any closets I said you
can just say return me these as a string
right you are returning one column is a
string and room will do it for you very
similarly what if we are returning ID
and title and that case again room will
say well there's two columns one string
that doesn't match it will give you an
error when that happens you can just
create a POJO again any class in your
application I think is we we can read
what's inside it and it matches what the
query returns we will generate the code
and to make the match you can you know
you can rename the columns in SQLite all
of those things works here now this room
does everything automatic about this
sometimes you have clauses we don't know
about now what they might kill to talk
about them
how do we expand room kill right thank
you so let's talk about and something a
little bit more interesting going back
to this Nancy do object that has one ad
integer field and two strings these are
primitive types that are directly
supported by the underlying SQLite
database what happens if we want to add
a field of a type that is not directly
supported by skew lights such as Java
util date in this case at compile time
room is going to tell us well I can't
really figure out how to save this you
need to help me out and the way you help
out in this case is provide cue methods
to take your original data
versus to something that sqf can store
so that is going into the database and
on the way out when you're doing the
queries convert back from that
representation in the database to your
original data type you implement these
two method in this particular case we
are converting data long and back from
long to date we annotate them as it said
we love annotations we use the type
conversion annotations on these two
methods and then we take this my
conversions class and use the type
converters annotation pointing to these
two methods pointing essentially to this
class that has our conversion methods
you can put it directly on the field in
your entity object you can put it on the
entity object itself you can put it onto
your there data access object class or
the specific query in it or you can put
it on your database class no matter
where you put it at compile time and at
runtime room will do the right thing to
find those two methods now with this we
can write a query that finds the list of
all the fields that were posted between
two specific dates from and two so here
since we are accessing the from and to
fields or columns in the database that
are defined as long when the database
table is created you don't really want
to use long as the implementation detail
since you are using the date class for
your entity data field you want to use
the date objects in the query itself and
this is what you do here and when the
query runs these two values from and two
are going to be converted to long the
query will run and on the way back when
room construct and fills these feed
objects is going to convert back from
long to days
now let's talk about even more
complicated stuff what happens if you
have a class ERG in your kind of data
model universe that has object graph
that is not flat in this case we are
adding a location object that has two
double fields latitude longitude into
our feed now what happens at compile
time
once again at compile time you need to
tell room how to store this field since
especially here it not even it's not a
primitive type but it's the types ax has
subfields in it so one option is going
back to our type adaptors you can do
something like take latitude and
longitude and convert them into a single
concatenated string with some kind of
let's say semicolon as a separator on
the way in and on the way back it's
going to be some kind of a split where
the string goes back through these two
doubles or you can go to do something
like bit masking and bit shifting to try
and convert these two doubles encode
them in one long field this is going to
be hard to query even for this simple
case when we only have two doubles that
we are trying to encode we're trying to
kind of compact it into one field and
the more complicated the data structure
is the harder it becomes to use type
adaptors for these cases another option
is to say that I'm going to flatten
everything that you are going to flatten
everything for us so instead of having
the location data field in your data
entity you are essentially flattening
all the fields from the location class
into the main seed class and then room
is going to create this to latitude
longitude columns which works but first
of all you lose the encapsulation now
you just look at the definition of your
data class of this feed object or
somebody else in your in your project
looks at that and it's not really clear
that these two objects kind of represent
one single entity and another thing is
just because you want to persist this
object and later on retrieve it why
should you be changing the definition of
your data classes that's not good
instead there's another option which is
also not ideal you can say we have a few
data classes why don't we store these
objects each one in its own separate
database table so we have our seed
object with ID title subtitle and posted
at the date and then we have the
location latitude longitude now in order
to connect them
not when you say but when you retrieve
them in order to connect the location
back to back to its feed you need to
have the primary key the CDD so that
they are combined together once again it
works first of all yet another table is
not very clean but also going back to
what I mentioned before why should you
be forced to change and tweak the
definition of your data model classes
just because you want to persist them so
what would be ideal is that you have
your clean separation of how you define
your data process but at some time the
way the feed object is persistent is in
one flatten table so essentially the
latitude and longitude fields from the
location are flattened into the same
table and the way you do it is with this
embedded annotation at compile time and
at runtime room is going to figure out
how to flatten your entire turkey into
this one table now you can write a query
like this in your data access object we
are going to select all the feeds in the
specific geographical rectangular area
as you can see we're referencing
latitude and longitude in the query
directly they are not in a separate
table and you are just using the same
names for the database columns as the
attributes in your location object you
can write a query like this to select
the location for the specific feed based
on the CID and room is going to figure
out that while it needs to fetch the
entire row from the database it only
needs to create and feel the location
object because this is what this time
method wants to return or if you want to
be more specific you can say I only want
you to fetch the latitude and longitude
from the table
the last part about embedded objects is
what happens when you have more than one
field of the same kind of nested class
so in this case we want to store two
locations so what is going to happen at
compile time room is going to say as I
was flattening these fields in two
one database table definition I see that
the same latitude field is defined by
two objects and since SQLite doesn't
support having two columns with the same
name in the same database table it's
going to fail as an error not as a
warning and what you need to do is in
case you do want to have something like
this to have in this particular case two
locations you want to use the prefix
attribute on the embedded annotation at
compile time and at run time it's going
to be used as roommates flattening the
data graph definition it's going to use
these prefix to create latitude
longitude for the original for the first
location and seen what if you'd still
longitude for the second location object
now let's talk about observer ability
for those of you who have listened to
yesterday's introduction session and who
have been here at them earlier in the
day to listen to the life cycle live
data view model we want to talk about
observability so this is a simple query
that returns the list of feeds based on
particular query this is kind of a
snapshot a point in time where you have
run this query and however many seeds it
returns it represents the state of your
data universe at that particular moment
what happens if your data is dynamic it
can be manipulated directly by your
users in the app or maybe it's push to
pull them from the server so in this
case if one of the feed changes in the
database when you add new feeds when you
delete existing feeds that match this
query every single time to reflect these
changes back onto the screen you would
need to refresh this query explicitly to
run this query again and again instead
instead of returning list of seeds you
can wrap this return object it can be a
single feed or a list of feeds in a live
data object this instructs true not only
to fetch it one
but also update the live data the
callbacks that you pass to the live data
when you call the dot observe will see
it in a few slides every single time any
one of the objects that were returned by
this query was changed or new objects
were added or existing objects were
removed from the result of the query and
this is my favorite part by far of an
architecture components and also we
provide support for using flow both from
our X Java tube so let's see like this
one ok so let's see an example of how
room integrates with the rest of life
cycle aware and life cycle where parts
of architecture components we're going
to start with a simple database
interface it has one method to load a
data for the specific user and one
method to save the data the first time
is going to be a simple insert and then
as the data changes is going to be an
update or replace as you can see here
instead of returning the user object
directly in our load method we're
returning a live data that wraps the
information about this user now we're
going to set up the data binding to
actually show the information on that
user
perhaps in the detail stage or somewhere
in some kind of a profile page we have
our life cycle activity it can be a life
cycle fragment it can be a life cycle
service or your custom life cycle owner
in this case we're using a life cycle
activity and in oncreate we're going to
get access to our database and database
access object we're going to call our
load method that returns the live data
that wraps at user data and now we are
going to use the observe method on this
live data object passing two parameters
the first parameter is the reference to
the lifecycle owner this is our activity
and the second parameter is the callback
that is going to be invoked by a room at
runtime every time this user information
changes in the database on the first
load or on the subsequent updates now
word of caution because it's kind of
like you know we don't want to put too
many lines of code here
on one slide you usually don't want to
kind of expose database details or
details about loading this information
from your web service or caching it
locally in some form directly to the
activity or directly to the fragment so
this code is highly recommended to be
put in a view model and once again the
most powerful part here is this
connection between the lifecycle
activity the owner that says I'm active
I am NOT active and the live data the
trim returns as a result of this
particular query this callback the
callback that you provide as the second
parameter to the method once again is
going to be invoked every time room
detects that the result of that query
that you wrote select star from the user
database table has changed once again
the flow of information is one part of
you app it can be some kind of a service
that pulls information from your
back-end or maybe the information is
pushed or some kind of network tickles
it gets updates on the data it's using
this save method to insert the
information into the database or update
the existing information as the data is
updated in the database room is going to
detect at runtime all those active
places in your app activity fragment
service or your custom lifecycle owners
that are active and that are subscribed
or observing a live data object that
traps the information that has been
updated and then this callback is going
to be invoked letting you know that most
probably you want to update whatever
slice of data is right now showing in
the application screen so for example it
can be an app that shows live results
for some sports games or live updates
for the web for weather wherever you
happen to be all live updates to a
market stock prices one part of your app
handles the data flow get that
information and display and and they
insert it into the database or
date in the database and the other part
gets notified by room and the live data
that the information is now has like you
know new new data and you need to update
whatever the presentation is once again
in your activity in your fragment or in
your service that post may be
notification of handles a widget thank
you so let's focus on another important
topic which is relations now SQLite is a
relational database so it can understand
the relations between entities and if
you are using any or M on androids or
like any other platform they usually try
to handle these relations for you so
let's look at it how it works in room so
we we feed we probably also has a user
object which has posted this feed item
so you want to have a user field inside
that field inside that entity if you do
this in room it actually won't compile
the application the moral of the story
we don't allow entities to contain other
entities now you're probably asking why
everybody else does this and if we can
understand all this SQLite why can't we
just enable this now there's a very
particular reason for us not to this is
we have seen a lot of problems with
applications caused by these kind of
models so I just want to go through an
example so first let's look at this
query strikes to select a feed with some
ID when we select this feed or when you
look at this feed item you cannot know
whether it also fetches the user or not
it's very hard to define and most of the
oil Rams the way they solve this problem
is to just say lazy loading right until
the user wants to fetch that data don't
load it which works very well if you are
working on the server side but on the UI
it is a little bit more tricky so let's
implant that lazy loading right you
could just generate this code for you we
could say I just keep a user ID also
keep a user instance when they get used
it is called because if the user is the
first time now
Edge's from the database otherwise just
return the existing girl work it's very
easy we believe this is a Chilean mine
planted in your code base let's see how
we explode it we are using a recycling
bin where we show these feed items and I
will get the faith and will show the
title and the subtitle of the feed item
so looks fine and I'm like two months
later your product manager comes
actually you know what let's show the
user name in that feed icon as well
right it makes sense like okay so easy
your developer goals just add now feed
get user get user name put it on the
TechSoup you are done you send the code
real it looks obvious it passes the code
real you test it it looks fine as well
but when your users start using it and
any application starts singing these NS
which stands for application not
responding
this happens because when you are
testing the application your own device
is good Network everything is fast but
when the user is using their application
there is public 50 applications that are
also trying to run and if you want to
relate to this just try to use your
application when Placer is updating your
applications you will see how it is I
mean these are still mobile devices at
least on these devices like accelerated
is slower so and the UI thread only has
16 milliseconds so even if your credit
takes 5 milliseconds like ignore all the
likes and everything here is 5
milliseconds 5 milliseconds a lot of
time you can probably like lay up to any
recycle of use at that time so how do
you solve this problem we through now
previously we said SQLite is a
relational database right we should just
take advantage of it we just keep the
user ID we know the feed is a user ID
just keep it and now we can write a
query they say I want title subtitle and
user name and join me these two tables
on this constraint like this is already
a solved problem on the SQLite land why
don't we just embrace it when you do
this it's faster you're on the fetch the
data you need and
my official data you know that data is
in memory our sake wait what is this
item let's see it can be like any Java
class it may even have a constructor
with public fields on the final fields
room will set this without any
reflection we will use that constructor
you can even see return a light data
because room knows about the query it
knows it's creating these two tables
like think about the other example if
you were observing the feed if the user
changes how do we know should be emailed
at the feed or not but when you wrote
this we actually know we know what you
are returning we know which tables you
are creating so we can be clever about
this so it's what we tell people if you
want to have relations and you cannot
use embedded or type adaptors you
probably want to use poles for your
relations which means you don't have any
hidden costs you only fetch what you
need and it's still observable and you
don't need to do anything for that but
of course we said SQLite is relational
and supports foreign keys room support
foreign keys as well so inside your
entity you can say this entity has a
foreign key to this other entity where I
want to match the ID column in that
entity with this child column SQLite
foreign keys also support like you may
have multiple fields matching multiple
fields in the other tables it's very
complex you should just go ahead and
read but once you declare this now
SQLite knows about this relationship if
it knows you can say things like you
know what if someone tries to delete
that users don't let them delete because
I have a feed for them or you can say if
that user is updated please update me as
well so we trying to embrace SQLite
rather than trying to hide these details
and like create a bunch of pitfalls it
makes it is another great thing now the
SQLite keeps the data on the disk in a
structured way so that you can query
effect as I'm going to clear like this
where you want to select feed items
which has a certain title but if you
just write this query and don't do
anything else
that means SQLite needs to go through
every single row
in the database to find the ones that
are matching now if you're not making
this very frequently that's fine but
this is the query that you run
frequently you probably want to index it
it's very simple in room you just inside
enter the annotation you can say well
can you please index the script in this
column if your queries like this where
you have like you query title and
subtitle together you can also create a
composite index which means these two
things will be indexed together so if
you are querying together that will be
fast and you can have multiple indices
like it doesn't matter by the way like
just because you're creating something
doesn't mean you should index it because
every index you add has a cost on every
insertion or data change so you need to
be you need to just measure and see why
what's the best way and a SQLite
documentation on query planner is
amazing like if you read that you will
know how to write queries and how to
optimize it now testing we know in the
past we haven't been very good in this
area but when we were designing
architecture components testing was a
very very important topic for us we want
to take whatever we create for
architecture components that they can
scale and that can be testable so let's
look at how you can run test your
queries by there you should really test
just because we are refining your SQL
queries doesn't mean that that's what
you really intended right this your java
code compiles but you still test it
similarly if your roommate scale
compiles you should still test it what
testing room is actually is and now we
student comment testing on the device
but there is no activity or UI so they
run faster you can also test on the JVM
by changing the SQLite bindings videos
say say in a way I'm just going through
a sample case so before each test is
created I create my database but I
create an in-memory database which means
the data little created man the test
starts and I can clean it afterwards you
want these tests to run isolated from
other tests
so you don't want to say the data into
disk so I said after just closed the
database so the memory can be released
fast and I can write it as Lewis this is
just like I create an item I inserted
the room and then make some queries on
it and I verify that this what I expect
but the way room is designed actually
helps with the overall application
testing do you remember we talked about
those doll classes we generate because
you defined how you access the database
as an interface which has nothing to do
with SQL you can very very easily mock
it so if you have a V model that you
want to test first of all you can't test
view models on the on your computer you
don't need to run them on the device you
can create a mock of that towel you can
just use more Kito to mark it and now
you can write a test like this like when
load feed with this parameter is called
return these feeds because it's just a
Java interface like there is not even
any mention of database - this is all
very well abstracted without you doing
anything now migrations is another
important topic right so if you use the
application over time your entities will
change they fear this user object now we
start the show user photos so you wanted
to add this name field into that if you
do that when you run the application as
soon as room like your first access the
database room of the herbs looks like
you change the schema but you didn't
increase the version it's going to crash
your application now you need to handle
this you can simply Inc you increase
your database version in the annotation
which means you don't want any of the
previous data you want to start from
scratch or you can write a migration now
to write the migrations in our database
builder you can just test a couple of
migration implementations like this one
says I know how to migrate from one to
two you can have one from 2 to 3 3 to 4
and then rule will run whatever
necessary from the current version on
the device to your latest version it
will just chain them and if anything in
the middle is
Simmonds going to recreate the database
another important to know in these
migrations don't use any constants
always useful SQLite because over time
your application will change those
constants may change and you will get
bugs okay we wrote this but like we said
testing is important right so room also
comes with a testing maven artifact like
we carry separate objects so that you
can test your migrations now this is a
couple of steps first when we compile
room we can actually ask room to export
the schema this how your database looks
into some JSON files which you should be
committing to your version control
system pass argument and then we want
these skill files to be visible to our
tests right so that we can access them
last but not least for our Android test
we add this Neve dependency from room
which includes some helpful classes that
will help us with our migration testing
so let's say we are trying to test a
migration from version 1 to 3
this is this migration test helper comes
which comes from that artifact we create
an instance of that helper this
canonical name is how room x-force these
files by default need to think about
much and we create an open helper
Factory
once we have that we say ok migrate from
1 to 3
we ask helpful to create a database at
version 1 like you may even have
entities that doesn't exist anymore it
doesn't matter because it did export the
schema previously by reading that it can
recreate your database in that version
you can just change it directly you can
do whatever you want but it is you
realize this doesn't return your dog it
just returns your database instance
because Dahl may not be valid anymore
you can just say run these migrations
and will date the schema oh there we
give the database day we give it to
version we want now you may have tables
that you had before and maybe you want
to keep them but don't tell them about
it so you can decide whether we should
check for these or not
and now you give a list of migration so
I have these are the old migrations we
have most of the room please migrate the
database from the previous version to
the new version and then check the
schema for you and then you can also
have like if you have custom things have
changed
entities in the previous versions to the
new versions then you can manually
assert on these things
okay so that was room we have a detailed
documentation page on the documentation
on the web page why do you like like we
do for room also for all our
architecture components we have a
testing artifact which includes one rule
for a unit on one rule for your
instrumentation test that how is it
dealing with the background threads
videos so we want to make sure
everything we have here is testable and
if it is not we all fix it so what's
next for you room is available today
please go check it like play with it
see how it looks check out the warp
renders come / arch which is the main
page for all of these architecture
components now we say these can work
independently but these also work very
well together is you seen in the live
data example Creole hat so check it out
and also check out the code labs we have
colors for both room and lifecycles and
they're available in the code lab pants
thank
[Applause]
[Music]